[Música]
solamente que no suceden solos se crean
tengo 24 años
cuando tenía 16 años tomé una de las
decisiones más importantes en mi vida
me corrieron de mi casa
y cuando digo que yo lo elegí es porque
yo hice todos los méritos necesarios
para que esto sucediera
cuando me fui
me llevé las pocas cosas que tenía
y tenía 50 pesos en mi bolsa
me subí a un camión realmente no tenía
hacia un rumbo adónde ir
solamente quería avanzar hacia adelante
y arriba del camión se acercó y se subió
un chavo con su guitarra a cantar
y entonces
se puso en medio de todos y empezó a
tocar
automáticamente todas las miradas se
fueron hacia él incluyendo la mía cuando
terminó pidió dinero paso por el pasillo
y todos le dieron cuando pasó al lado
mío yo le di diez pesos inmediatamente
me hice esta pregunta porque acababa de
darle a ese chavo el 20% de mi único
ingreso que tenía en ese momento
y entonces me hice otra pregunta
es que tanto puede impactar porque no
era lo que canto sino era la conexión
que le había generado con todos los que
estábamos ahí
y entonces me hice esta tercera pregunta
qué tanto puede impactar con mi voz
yo podría generar lo mismo
y fue así
que tome mis cosas me bajé del camión
me fui por mi guitarra
y empecé a cantar
bueno
[Música]
quiero que la protagonista me visto
antes y estamos eso lo que es feliz y
siempre está presente y gasta su tiempo
sólo en complacerme eres algo más que el
amor de mi vida
con motivo de mis alegrías cuando estoy
contigo lo corre las horas porque tienes
todo lo que me enamora
eres en pocas palabras la mejor de todas
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
gracias
y entonces
después de ahí
con todos los nervios
viendo a toda la gente
hace 8 años pasé también por los
pasillos y la gente me empezó a dar
dinero
me bajé ni siquiera podía ver a nadie a
los ojos
y tan insegura que me sentía de tan
nerviosa que me sentía pero quise ver mi
resultado así que me puse a contar todo
el dinero
y en menos de cinco minutos había
generado 200 pesos
dije sí
si impacta
mi voz claro que impacta
y entonces comencé a hacerlo todos los
días
una y otra vez y empecé a generar
clientes en general
pero no tenía un propósito claro de para
que estaba juntando ese dinero no tenía
un propósito claro de para que hacía lo
que estaba haciendo
y entonces
después de eso
está en un lugar en el cual tampoco
tenía propósito para estar ahí pero
tampoco tenía uno para dejar de hacerlo
entonces
después
empiezo a hacer un montón de cosas que
no funcionaban
me alejé de mi familia
dure más de un año sin verlos tenía
amistades tóxicas
y nada de lo que hice todo ese tiempo me
estaba acercando a algo no tenía un
propósito claro de nada
cuando cumplí 20 años conocí el coaching
y decidí empezar a hacerlo parte de mi
vida
decidí a empezar a actuar de forma
distinta
decidí parar
mirar elegir
voy a empezar a accionar distinto
y fue así que comencé a estudiarlo
y realmente actuar en congruencia con
eso
y lo más importante encontré mi
propósito de vida y entonces empecé a
impactar con mi voz de una forma
diferente
después de eso
y comencé a estudiar más
y lo que sucedió después fue que también
hubo muchas consideraciones en ese
momento había mucha gente que me decía
que era muy joven para tal vez enseñarle
a otros sobre la vida
también mucha gente me decía que tal vez
la gente no me iba a respetar que iba
haber muchísima gente con más
experiencia que yo
incluso otras personas me llegaron a
decir que como me iban a querer si para
de enfrente tenía cara de bebé
pero nada de eso me importó
porque mi propósito era aún más grande
mi propósito
era seguir arriesgando para seguir
compartiendo
soy coach ontológico y transformacional
la ontología del lenguaje es el estudio
del ser humano basado en las emociones
he trabajado con adultos adolescentes y
niños para cumplir metas tanto
profesionales personales familiares
y durante todo este camino cuando yo
decía que estaba bien normalmente me
repetía esta frase
pues no pasa nada hay que vivir el
presente
pero cada vez que yo me decía eso
anteriormente
eso solo me llevaba a tener resultados
que no quería
dentro de mi generación hubo una moda
online no solo
john lilly ones sólo se vive una vez
y entonces era sólo para todos yo no me
drogo yo lo pongo el cuerno yo lo empleó
hasta las 6 de la mañana
yo lo hago lo que quiera
yo no no pasa nada
pero porque no me atreví a decir yo no
hago ejercicio
yo lo pongo mi empresa
yo lo me comprometo en una relación
cuando realmente empecé a comprometerme
y empecé a entender que no solamente era
estar parado en el presente sino tener
ese presente con una proyección hacia el
futuro y entonces cuando yo estoy clara
de mi verdadero propósito que es más
grande que lo que estamos viviendo en
este momento es ahí donde la valentía
aparece donde entonces nada me ha podido
parar ni las críticas ni el juicio ni el
miedo ni la vergüenza ni lo que he
pasado
uno de los propósitos más grandes
que yo me hice
fue recuperar la relación con mi familia
y ha sido de mis mejores proyectos
hoy en día tenemos una increíble
relación
y es algo de lo que no me arrepiento y
lo prefiero mil veces que todas las
cosas superficiales que preferían antes
aún siendo coach yo seguía cantando en
los camiones
aún siendo coach porque yo quería seguir
demostrándole a la gente que se requería
seguir teniendo humildad
que todo era posible que no podía ir
escalando significa
que había que dejar por cómo empezaste
ah
dentro d
todo lo que he aprendido lo más
importante que me he llevado
es la valentía
pero no se puede ser valiente si no
sabes para qué quieres serlo
cuando tengo mi propósito claro dice que
es más grande que cualquier otra cosa
entonces sé para qué quiero ser valiente
y elijo serlo todos los días y seguir
primero transformando me a mí misma pero
también apoyando a toda la gente que se
acerque y la que no se acerque también a
que también lo logré
y que tengan una visión de vida clara
para que sepan para que ser valientes
no puede ser sincero si no eres valiente
no puede ser amoroso si no eres valiente
no puedes confiar si no eres valiente
incluso no puedes experimentar la
realidad si no eres valiente entonces la
valentía va primero y todo lo demás va
después muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]